linan a back foot snapshot
a generous bounce pble zaka
s pble zaka brings the bru back from two goals
down to beat Florida throw the cat off the cliff
well pav zag is such a well-conditioned hockey
player strong makes good plays smart he's getting
more and more comfortable he looks over the
coverage and peels back that much time in the
power play here's mccan Jared mccan will move out
res situate with Bor strand done mccan scores hey
hey what do you say Jared mccan and the Kraken get
it done once again in overtime here's the motion
York Strand cross seam right to the one-time and
MCC at the top of the circles good Puck movement
able to attack through the middle and again mccan
sa jet went at 35 seconds to go in the overtime
Keandre Miller does he have another gamewinner in
that stick beneran saan J he scores they did it
the Rangers have swept the road trip five for
five M aanad wins it in overtime and makes no
mistake here are the Rangers with the change
watch the pass from paner and bang game over
paner and third point of the game for Zan Jad now
goals him backto back turn back fors oh off the go
post here's Raymond again across back scar
Raymond for coer and the Red Wings win a final
score of 4 to three their first win at four
what a comeback Victory by [Applause] Detroit
four that couldn't handle the puck and
can unlike the Islanders a p they had
a lot of turnovers didn't they in this
game in the red Wings good on them and
a lot of this has to do with the Red
Wings really getting on the Islanders